yeah so i went to 10th planet
based off rogan you know telling me yeah
man you you know you got the cheer
background you know how the flips
flexible but white he was just thinking
you need something to do no he wanted he
was like i think you'd be really good at
it and then
also at the same time you don't know you
right also at the same time i'm like i'm
i'm 33 though
and i win it's a commitment and i was
like it's just a different level of
training i was like oh
i this is something i need to do as a
young guy yes i was like i don't need to
be doing this right now but yeah
i got [ __ ] also i remember the fact i
didn't have any money take forever i
don't have any money
it's expensive i started i trained
jiu-jitsu
in earnest for long enough where i where
i got my blue belt from hensel gracie
where i come to l.a
training all the time and then one day i
never i was like 33
and i had i really was really working at
it like you know for
for a long time yeah and i never forgot
this i never got it
we were in ghee and the teacher goes
guys a lot of you guys are putting your
hand like that
you have to put your hand like this like
that and i went like this
i was watching i go i don't care
i remember i i
better yeah you can do it correct
correct me too if you do jiu jitsu
the drive the training the shower it's a
two hour
it's it's a lot at least two hour
commitment it's a it's a lot yeah i even
i go slow i went to what is that um
kickboxing i went to one of those class
what am i doing yeah i went to one i
went to one of those
kickboxing classes i don't know what you
want man but
you can shave like those cardio boxing
i like the getting in shape that we do
at zoo culture working out that's fine
that's very rich
hey what are you trying to say for your
heart man your blood pressure some
some cardio well my blood pressure good
we'll see
when you're right you know it used to be
it used to be bad it used to be crazy
and then and then because i was crazy
but what uh because i go get a yearly
checkup just because i'm just crazy and
i just want to know
and uh uh but then with it that's
completely normal oh okay well everyone
looks at me crazy like why don't you get
a check on there you're responsible
you literally check up yeah that makes
sense oh okay
and uh within recent years go uh
going in because usually they would have
to check my blood pressure twice
because it'd be high when i get in there
yeah and then yeah
but first try now always good
it's insane yeah did you get on
medication no
i stopped taking that medication because
i was like because because i was like
how long do i have to take this
and they were like oh you just they
didn't really give me like a timeline
but also there's a lot of things you can
do with
blood pressure naturally basic things of
like working out
the way you eat and like all if you like
watching this
so my biggest thing was stress because
of my you know how i grew up
my childhood home so like so it was just
chaotic so it was like i was just
constant
on on edge you know what i mean like i
remember
when i found out i had high blood
pressure i was i was like
17 or 18. i was about to get in a fight
at school
and my chest just kept like uh pumping
and the security guard was like hey man
you know we're
we're good now like you you calm down
shut it off and i was like i was like
i can't stop it he goes oh we got to
take you to the nurse then and the nurse
took my blood pressure and she was like
he's got to leave school now
like he's he's got to go to you know me
and me and my father or my mother have
low blood pressure
always like would never have really yeah
so what yeah what is yeah what does that
entail
just lucky oh like we got high pressure
we don't
wait you mean low like no no have you
been
one up or over i know oh you struggle
with heartbreak
wait is it dude my whole family nothing
so you mean it's normal it's about to
say
i also have really good eyes i don't
need glasses i don't mean that guy
you know the guy we're making fun of
where the guy who goes i have five
bachelor's degrees
i don't know just like three minutes i
just didn't help it
i just i just thought to myself my mom
called my dad
is you know if your dad had high blood
pressure you got a body kill so can we
relate that's it
it's like it's called no keep it a
conversation trying to say this
you're better than you're never gonna
die that's not saying you are you're
immortal you're immortal which means i
win
yeah your family is better than me you
want to make sure you knew his family's
better friend was better than what
weird man no we didn't grow up with any
of that trauma we had money and cheating
dude we're just like
uh my biological father the gangster he
lost him a bunch of weight
certainly yeah he started really uh
working on his health no no no
he just started working on his health uh
his papa was thick
yeah did he come out of jail thick uh
yeah he did he came out of jail yeah
remember you know what they feed them
weights and stuff or was he just
losing weight i don't know he was just
[ __ ] he's just a gangster yeah
yeah he was it was it's he's so he's so
crazy yeah
see that would be you could relate to me
there we go there we go
now we got something very good here he's
got him your dad was not your dad's fat
he's bringing it out here being the
mediator for us right now trying to help
yeah he's trying to take this palette
where do we get that i'm in here's your
dad
well your dad's [ __ ] that's when i
chairman i want to mention
sixty-five heavier than that bubba you
did you got six four
yeah wait how hey giant head you're dead
is your sister tall yeah
it's like two fifty deadline no no well
he does that guts out there here dude
yeah and he's my height you did
yeah yeah well he's got his guts out to
him yeah but he doesn't he reads
the book sets on his skeleton
and by the way and i go crazy because
he'll eat
all the bananas in an hour and then i go
i go
you ate all the bananas and he goes no
[ __ ] he goes no i didn't
and i go you're lying to me your food at
issue is
is amazing yes
is your mom tall my mom is five foot
four sir
oh okay maybe five two i'm sorry my
mom's five two and that side of the
family is slight
they're slight i got that jean yeah
that's what i was gonna say because
pop pop how tall is your sister then
papa's bit like frankenstein though it
wasn't like he was a giant he was pretty
coordinated but not a slow yeah a lot of
slow twitch muscle
okay and they couldn't run fast or
anything but big throw cats and throw a
ball real well
all that stuff i grew up doing it
wisconsin
yeah some brother was a good athlete but
probably
well you have a brother and a sister now
hold on
mother had a trial for the brewers oh
[ __ ]
yeah it was a good picture you could
throw with his leftover yeah
yeah high school america so they they
have a draft and we can look it up
and i hate to do this here's the thing
so
these major league teams don't have
tryouts that's the thing
you either get drafted and you're going
to camp he went to camp
he went to bruce camp lasted two days
that's what he said lasted two days now
it's got it's kind of like
i wish i could now the college thing is
a day is a tough one for me because
uh usually i think as you as you speak
this way
the family story was yeah yeah you went
to the see here's the thing
when you start going at 54. he's dead
now so i can talk
yeah you can't do it at 54 he said
i'm now realizing because he had a
tryout with the brewers he went to camp
with the brewers
i know he didn't go to college so that's
the first hiccup
yeah that's okay though baseball you can
get away it's okay because high school
players so you go
but don't you go through the you go
through the the minor leagues you go
through my own
you don't so here's the usually like
unless you're a big prospect you're not
going straight to the major no no never
so single a double a triple i didn't
hear it i didn't hear word one about
single a
triple a double a so then he was really
good why right
is that is that because he was really
right is that a family line
the family lies that he didn't he didn't
go
he didn't go to camp for the brewers
there's not a shot
it's a bummer right do you think now can
you give me this at least
tell me he was at least an all-american
in high school
he didn't have good grades so that might
get in the way that's why he didn't get
in oh that's why is that what
makes sense just though degrades great
there's no
great athlete has ever gotten by with
bad grades
yeah that's why you didn't make it so
this is all coming together now it's a
bummer so you'd say i've had to deal
with this in my family
damn you line it all up man and also he
could throw
just as fast with his writing that may
not be true either
so there's a lot of stuff that i've been
i've been told huh it's a fun story
though
it's a fun story for the family it's a
fun story for the family and don't go to
the family and tell them we debunked
this you know
like yeah keep the story you got to keep
it my dad my dad
um my dad i started crying one time
because i got i got
hypothermia when i was 15 too young
too old to cry yeah i was skiing i'm in
hypothermia i got over there i was like
i couldn't i wasn't crying but i was
going uh but i got cry baby i was
probably crying and my dad
said to me um my dad said
hey suck it up i got shot
and i didn't cry and i went for a long
time good father
a long time i was like my dad got shot i
can't be a [ __ ]
so that's what you think about all the
time now yeah it stuck with that i got
older and i did he get shot i got over
here
i said uh i was about to connect you
because my dad got shot could i
be old that i believe yeah
really yeah the uh a piece of the bullet
was still in his hand and
they had to take it out when he went to
prison
remember when i was 15 and i had
hypothermia or 14 and i was
and you said i got shot i said can i see
that
old bullet wound because never seen
turns out he went well that didn't
happen
he's just trying to make sure you're
just trying to get me toughen up hey
i get it it's still lying now yes still
and it's all
more like i feel like there's other
things you could use there's some strong
lies in there yeah
you know like shot down i've always said
i i may fib but i don't
lie live no no no no what's like last
night i was taking tiger's
jitsu it at the end they always haven't
played freeze tag these two kids ran
into you know they're
wilding out they ran each other and this
kid he's bigger than all the he's still
older than everyone and he his hair is
all ridiculous and he will not stop
crying like
okay someone needs to get this kid and
it's [ __ ] up the game because he's
howling i'm like ooh man
he's probably [ __ ] nine cr i mean
howling like okay
and then i go over and i'm like is he
all right does he need it he's like
i don't see anything i'm like all right
keeps howling
and then finally tiger we're leaving he
goes and we're like putting our shoes on
by him ty goes
dad he must be really hurt he keeps
crying i go
that or he's a giant [ __ ]
sometimes there's sometimes there's not
much you can say i said
you and it's okay to cry if you're hurt
it's okay to cry yeah but clearly he's
dealing with something more than that a
little bit more than that but
you're pretty tough as a kid though yeah
no not really i'm not tough now
i i mean i want to be i love your honor
i will say this you did beat the shout
out to christian
dude we didn't get that on video either
yeah yeah you did you have a video
all right that's all i thought a lot no
i don't want to who posted it i don't
want it
kidding i think christian posted it
saying he got [ __ ] up no
yeah i saw him like
driving so yesterday we did a bonus just
me and brian
we had a little whiskey things got
pretty rowdy and then you guys kept
[ __ ] with me yeah a little whiskey
you guys want to pretend you were
bouncing i slapped your face
and they said hey we're bouncers i bet
we could kick you out of the room i said
i don't think so
not even remotely close happening that's
whatever but the thing is and then
christian who's
21 years old yeah you know grew up in
rhode island you know
a tough tough scrappy kid there he is we
call him meatball
people hate him the thing is is uh he
you know he's just
young and dumb because what happened was
he thought he could [ __ ] with callan and
the clown's like all right let's do it
dude
no no what happened was i said yeah he
he said what what are under hooks and i
said well here's
no and i said here there's there's a
series of underhooks that you can do
that's that was me being a shot of brian
that that's right
that's that ground that ground pound
right now that hair is tough but we got
to get changed the lighting because that
hair i look
you're just completely suffering yeah oh
you're right here right here right here
see now now because he tried to wrestle
with me
i had to i thought you can go ankle pick
on it yeah i was in fact in fact i was
right
what do they call that i just don't care
enough dude i would have beat the
[ __ ] of both of you would have
shattered my wall back there now you see
this
[Applause]
that's just why is he grabbing your leg
oh he tapped
that wow and that was what 30 seconds
did you see how surprised he is like 10
seconds
he's so surprised
the point i'm making is that like so
what happened was i got under hooks and
then he started to wrestle with me
he wouldn't let me i was trying to show
him what to do and all of a sudden he
starts because everybody wants to test
the old man
yeah he tried to test things like me go
at it yeah and then i think chris was
like oh i could beat up kids yes
and so what what christmas understand is
that it's still a language i speak to a
degree you have more experience than
anybody besides me and
that's exactly that's if you're gonna
wrestle with me i'm probably gonna
i could probably have a couple tricks up
my sleeve yeah and if you're that much
smaller and you're christian you don't
maybe you did some wrestling i don't
think you wrestled you're not gonna
he has a video right this is like the
top video on there just saw some yeah
no no on his like post post that video
look at the right one
the point i'm making is that christian
and chen always want to box with me
right i've been boxing long like and
long enough
obviously brennan will knock me the [ __ ]
out but if you've never
boxed like christian and you're that
much smaller
it's not going to go well it's going to
go about the same way
they might try to wrestle with
that's right now now chin i wanted chin
to feel your power
yesterday so that was a setup i we said
uh we're bouncers i'm going to try to
get brennan out of the room
which was fun which is very good and
brandon god was an unruly i
didn't want i want this to be known i
didn't want to do any of it no i was
trying you never do
no never did i made him cause i want
because chin said i want to surprise
brennan with what i got
jenna has a lot of confidence i didn't
want to do it you you said those
exact words physicality and he's not a
weak guy if he trained and worked out
he'd be a handful yeah
but chin doesn't understand that brendan
is what's called a professional
fighter professional athlete and also a
manaconda
he's the anaconda so uh so what i did is
i said chin up i checked
no no no hey dude that's not what i
meant i'm sorry no no no no no no you
got it oh my god yeah
yeah yeah
i set him up and i i exited the
equations
i thought we were going to work together
oh that's a good idea
if you were to grab one you would have
pushed you would have just sprawled and
snapped your neck that's
the problem to this that i know it looks
soft carpet no no that would have been a
problem no
i've had my head sprawled on by you and
i had an ear nightmare i had a tattoo
i had a redneck on my ear for yeah yeah
that's not you know what hurt the most
is when you put me down there
and then my neck was right this way that
was like that's the scene not the choke
it was just oh that's that's
that's what it's for yeah oh okay
supposed to break your neck that was the
stop stop that was good you could break
your [ __ ] neck
yeah that was very very good did you tap
immediately no i've had i tried
you didn't like try to do that that was
20 yeah before
because if you don't know what you're
doing you're like i'm not losing
oxygen i should be all right it's so
much pressure on your [ __ ] neck
before you by the way [ __ ] insane by
the way before you uh chin before you
feel bad about that
i i have i know for a fact that old man
akanda here has done that to a lot of
black belts too
he's gotten some high level black belts
in that that his bread and butter
darce and that are as bread and butter
and he gets that seat belt on you no
matter who you are
i don't care if you're conor mcgregor
you you can tap yeah
you know i didn't realize so i already
knew brendan's like super strong but
like i just couldn't you're so heavy i
couldn't
i couldn't push him what did you think i
thought i'd be at least able to push him
a little bit black belt
he didn't budge i was like he put me in
a slight chokehold and i was like
pro athlete i said that to roger hey
they thought they were bouncing kicking
me out a bar
and he goes idiots i didn't want to do
it brian
you got to feel it you had a feeling
that was a total setup you played a good
unruly let's watch this later very good
we got 355
5 000. hello let me
oh
[Laughter]
i'd already gotten beaten up so i didn't
want to that was a bad move right there
very bad
he can't move him it's just
this is a christian laugh look at chin's
feet here watch i know
i feel so helpless i felt so helpless
that's the old that's the old
what do they call that move what do they
call that would you say
yeah this is prison daddy's getting his
nuts out
that's the scariest thing to think about
too like he could do whatever he wanted
that's
that's exactly that's very freaking
scary
picking a hole on the wall and you're
gonna you're gonna go somewhere else i
have to go somewhere else yeah you have
to mentally go somewhere in my happy
place it's your happy place
because that old weathered honey hole
yeah that dry
honey hole that dusty honey yeah
the train's coming all right is that
right
the train's wet and hard oh boy yeah oh
boy
choo choo oh no don't choose you in my
ear
nah nah don't shoot your butt
now brian were you you were a killer in
high school in wrestling yeah
kill her i was a pretty good wrestler
yeah he was a good wrestler yeah i think
yeah just feisty christian
at first i was like oh christian better
not hurt [ __ ] brian so i guess i
needed to go i had to go pick up tiger
if i was a christian better not [ __ ]
hurt brian so that's why i stayed and
watched and then price
beat the [ __ ] as soon as i get the car i
take
my jay i go brian just beat the shout
out to chris well i called him i wanted
to make sure he wasn't hurt oh no he was
fine right yeah he was oh he was good
his facial expression says it all though
yeah he's just taking him he's so funny
but he couldn't believe it
because in the pictures that kyle said
he's like like when he's watching all
this wrestle he's like having the best
that's what happens to dudes who don't
know
anything about fighting against look at
the new guy who [ __ ] with uh homeboy
in the bar
that's right what with joe schilling if
you're gonna play with [ __ ]
snakes you're gonna get [ __ ] you're
gonna get bit you you're just
the snake knows how to move well you
have to understand that you're an
antelope and there are lions out there
and you're never or you're a dog and
they're a bear there's a standing joe
a world-class striker like i mean
world-class striker yeah yeah he was in
a bar
drinking and this guy kept like staring
at him like talking kind of [ __ ]
and then the guy had no clue i was like
no and the guy kept talking [ __ ] to like
the dj and the bartender
and then joe schilling like somebody's
feeling joe jones walking by and the guy
flexes on him
no he [ __ ] goes like this and joe
goes
knocks him out just just now now this
guy had the liquid courage and now the
guy's suing joe schill
he's doing them if i was a judge i'd
like what do you think was gonna happen
yeah what'd you think was matter of fact
you pay him thirty grand [ __ ] i agree
i hope and this is a cheap lesson for
you to learn
watch this it looks like a a movie
actually it does because it's the videos
right there you thought it was fantastic
let me see
if there's not when you finally
so the context before this guy's been
talking [ __ ] all night to the bartender
or the dj
that liquid courage look here comes joe
you can't like joe's like watch out man
then look joe
the guy said something joker's what you
got flex boom
ouch and what'd you think was it
just knocked him the [ __ ] look at how
fast
that's what a that's a pro fighter
that's a different thing dude
holy [ __ ] that's why but this is social
media in a nutshell
so all those people talking on social
media this is how it would go for you if
you this is how it would go
if you kept that standard energy and i
love it justice
when you meet someone i actually enjoyed
this i love it
yeah it's like would you love it what do
you think what do you think was gonna
happen it's like those idiots that try
and take selfies with the buffaloes in
yellowstone
they get real close and they're like
these [ __ ] buffalos rammed their
[ __ ] horn through my [ __ ] and
threw me 10 feet in the air it's like of
course
what's a buffalo you know in the gym
every once in a while there'd be a kid
who's athletic who would
get in there and try to actually spar
with a good
boxer like like a young they'd get in
there and they'd be like let's go
because they'd start sparring they're
kind of athletic and strong
and then you get a just some guy but
who's been throwing his right hand for
i don't know since he was 10. yeah and
what do you think happens
well you get hit in the liver or you get
caught and then you just go to sleep
and people just i don't understand it's
simply like completely
different side of the fence but similar
with and i'm so i was telling chappelle
about this went to
uh breakfast after i worked out today
we're i was telling about
i'm so into this i think it's just
because so far out of the realm of
anything i'm involved with you know
tekashi69 right
yeah he you know so he blew up
soundcloud all that stuff
in his marking genius you could say
blows the [ __ ] up
but he associates himself with the
bloods he's not a blood didn't grow up
that gangster life
but he's so he gets involved in that
world and they're repping for him
you know and he's paying them their you
know their security for him there's rap
videos
but you know that was his the life he
chose and then they get caught up
and he snitches and they all go to
prison for us for lives and he's out
free right
so everyone labels them a rat well dj
akademiks who has a
uh podcast on spotify's first episode
he's best friends with
six nine so on his first episode he has
akashi 69 he's a young man
24 and not knucklehead 24 but super
successful
at what he does he's 24. he hasn't sit
down this guy named whack 100.
well whack is like a o.g head of the
bloods like he's a real
gangster jesus like real gangster so
they have takashi sit
down with him and takashi's you know
going well they've they [ __ ] my girl
which is true he's like
those people you say you know he goes so
the rules of the street
loyalty right and uh wackos yep okay
that's out the window [ __ ] my
girl tried robbing me tried murdering me
so loyalty is at the out the window
and he goes and then snitching is
against rules right yep he goes so they
broke rule number one
i broke rule number two but i'm getting
[ __ ] for breaking two
although they broke one first he's like
that's the rule that's that's what you
signed up for dude
and he goes but i'm not mad at you this
is his gangster talking he goes i'm not
mad at you he goes
i don't label you a rat and even i was
like oh damn he goes you're not a rat
because you're a civilian and i expect
civilians when you're under the
pressure of the feds you're going to
flip because you're civilian that's what
civilians do
because you you act like you're a
gangster but you're not a gangster and
this shows that
because a real gangster when they get
caught it's our
number one rule you don't talk to the
feds you talk to the feds he goes
this is more on the bloods man because
they should never put you in that
position
you should have never been a blessing
because you're not a blood but you want
to act like one
but then when the com comes time to obey
the rules behave like a civilian
he goes because you're a civilian
because that's why i'm not mad at you
because i'm not mad at you at all for
that
and you're like oh [ __ ] but then you
that's so interesting it's so easy but
you hear this
so true too he's an older son that's
probably why
they didn't [ __ ] kill him that's and
he says that because they could kill him
well that but
and then so takashi 69 you can tell he's
just young and ignorant about things
and he starts naming off all these
rappers like you know he's like
nipsy hustle he sent guys after me when
i was in l.a from hotel to hotel and
this guy you know
he knows nipsey really well and he goes
see that's where you [ __ ] you don't know
what you're talking about
he goes trust me if we wanted to get to
you i forget what gang he's with
because we want to get to you there's no
good there's no neighborhood in the
world that can protect you
he goes we're not even thinking about
you're not that big of a deal now
because we want to get to we would have
got you back they just consider him
noise he goes if you know they would
have gone
and he goes he goes and why wouldn't we
give you because you're not a gangster
because you're a civilian entertainer
we're not worried about you
damn it's so fascinating so true dude
it's so
that is so but when you hear him can i
see what this guy looks like but
when you hear him break it down and then
you and then you real and then he
and then he goes well who's this with
you he's like this is my crew
and he's like these guys are down for
you so if there's gunfire these guys
jump in front bullet freight he goes
yes my crew he was everybody getting the
camera show your crew
that's him on the right on the right
like oh this is tough
that guy's the real deal oh dude the
real deal so the and then this is what's
interesting
super real deal so takashi keeps calling
himself a gangster and he keeps telling
him no
and he destroys them in the conversation
last night they get on i don't know why
i'm so into this but last night
they get on a thing called uh
clubhouse clubhouse i guess people get
on there and talk it's like a clubhouse
i guess
and uh stack uh yeah whack 100 is on
there with takashi 69
but also 21 savage who's a rapper is on
there
so uh you know 21. 21 savage gets on
there and he who's also a rapper
savage gets on there and he and he says
it to wax not face but over the over the
call he goes
yeah because takashi goes goes 21 savage
you keep making fun of people call
people rats who talk to me he goes bro
tell the truth you and i had a 45 minute
conversation last night dude
and 2017 was like yeah because i was
calling us no no you talked to me for 45
minutes dude
like man to man why don't you air that
out there to keep calm people
you know shitty for talking to me stuff
like that like just be honest like
everyone has all this [ __ ] on social
media but face face they're not doing it
and then 21 savage who's a young man and
who
uh whack 100 knows and he and any
and and then toga she goes hey 21 savage
tell whack
over this what you told me because you
were going to say to him 2017 goes yeah
i thought it was lame he sat down with
this rat
and you hear the the demeanor because
this this whack 100 and the whole
interview has been super calm
never raised his voice you can tell
nothing just he's seen some [ __ ] dude
yeah
and he goes now young man you and i have
met several times face-to-face and i
[ __ ] with you and we're respectful
he goes i don't i don't know the lingo
define lame for me
21 savage goes i i think it's [ __ ]
lame that you sat down with this rat
i think it's some bit [ __ ] dude and then
that [ __ ] whack on her goes [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he goes [ __ ] i will kill you
dude he goes you're in atlanta right now
he was i'll fly tell me where he at i'll
fly to atlanta right now because i'm not
even going to ball up my fist you [ __ ]
because i'm going to
you know what i'm doing i'm going to
whip your ass by slapping you i'm going
to [ __ ] slap dude and he's going
off and you're like holy [ __ ] yeah you
better you finally put him over the edge
you're like oh there he is yeah don't
[ __ ] around
like what i mean savage got off the goal
yeah he's going whack calm down man calm
down be cool man be
and he just get like hangs up yes that's
the thing with these guys
oh sure
you're an entertainer i'm a [ __ ]
gangster he goes send me
he goes i'll get on a plane right now i
will right now and fly to atlanta
you and me in a [ __ ] bathroom i will
beat the piss out of you
he's like young man i'm telling you next
time i see you
i don't care who you're with i'm gonna
walk up to you i'm gonna slap you in the
[ __ ] face and you're like
holy [ __ ] you're dealing with a dude who
solves his problems
that way that way that way but when you
hear that real gangster when he's
talking to takashi
takashi he's like he's like well snoop
sent a
uh nda and uh a seasoned assist because
i was trolling him online
like that's not gangster and then this
guy goes listen
i'm very close with snoop you gotta
realize snoop is a business snoop has a
hundred employees
stupid worried about you snoop has some
guy part of his business probably
attorney
saw you're throwing this [ __ ] out there
he sent you that soup
isn't even aware of any of this no he
goes and you're acting like it's so
personal these guys are doing that
snoop's moving a million miles an hour
he's not worried about what the [ __ ]
you're doing online
no he's like snoop's 55 years old man
god damn but he just
keeps so what goes on with this takashi
kid what's going on with him i think
it's just like
what we're talking about earlier like i
think it's just one of those kids that
just
got mixed up later in the game with
these bloods because like
i was telling you my my dad was in the
[ __ ] at 12.
you know what i mean like he what he
didn't start getting in yeah you know
you started running
but that's what whack 100 said he goes
you guys were
like you you in the in the bloods were
playing chess man you guys like
you benefited from them they benefit
from you but it was chess pieces and you
check made them when you snitched on
them
like you you got the you won he's like
and that's fine but
you guys agreed to do this thing and he
was how long were you in it young man he
goes
uh under 12 months and he was i really
think if you kept going like tupac did
you would eventually got into that
gang's real gangster lifestyle and he
would end up dead
he's like that's how this end for you he
goes no this is a happy ending
because dj academics was like well how
do you want to end this he's like i mean
none of this is a happy ending
this kid's gonna have to have security
for the rest of his life like he still
does now he does have to have security
because there are people after him i
mean yes and no like that's what uh
takashi was saying which even but the
real
even that whack 100 was like bro we're
worried about other gangsters well it's
like we're not
about entertaining these are businesses
too you know yeah like all these like
whether they're
a biker gang or they're like uh the gang
of whatever they're they're businesses
too they they really don't know
all about business they don't want the
no they don't want to kill a [ __ ] a
rapper just bring so much heat on it but
you got 669 where i do sidewind a little
bit he's like bro so
he's like he's like the the the rules of
this street life are [ __ ]
stupid man and wax was like yeah the
long they don't make a lot of sense man
he was like wait you think i got out i'm
in entertainment now
so so so he's like loyalty who had sex
with takashi's girl like one of
all his buddies all of them multiple
multiple guys had sex with his
girl his baby mama so he's like all
right well so she was just having sex
with all those guys behind his back yep
he's like right hand man so he was like
[ __ ] these guys then they tried robbing
and murdering him
so that's why takashi 69 is like these
why did they try to rob and murder him
did that happen after after he got mad
about his girl
uh they just it was like all at one time
so that's why takashi 69 is like
well they [ __ ] me over yeah so i get
pants and then what i didn't know too
is to akash six nine goes whack tell me
what you would have done
he goes so if the feds show up to your
house what's that mean
and why it goes it's over they got you
well you know the feds have a 98
confetti because by the time they when
they come they have all their
stevie told me that oh so they've got
all their ducks fetch up it's game
segments if you see those
black suvs come up and that's what
that's what they have they have the fact
that
she was in europe and they said oh the
fed just showed up to your house and
takashi's like oh
there it goes i'm [ __ ] there's like
there's no way to get out of it no so he
goes what would you have done
and uh whack when her goes i wouldn't
have snitched he was because i'm from
the street that's what i grew up with
like
he's like here's the difference he goes
in the the the mediator the the host dj
academics he goes he's a civilian
and dj then he says yep i don't know a
blood [ __ ]
terminology i'm not pretending to do and
he goes he goes so that whack 100 goes
so let's say i give 100 pounds of weed
to dj academics i go hey go deliver this
down the street
for me to i sold to this guy and the
cops pull him over
and he gets caught well i know he's a
civilian
and i gave him that that weed i know
he's not from the streets so he's going
to snitch on me because
that's not me yeah because i knew he
wasn't part of the the the gang
because now if i gave it to one of my
actual
you know members gang members he gets
caught i know for a fact he's not gonna
stitch on me because that's the way
that's the rules of the street he's like
that's the difference man so
that was his point he was like those
bloods who took you in and showed you
the ways that made you a blood even
though he had no business like you
weren't initiated in it like
that's on them man they should have
known you were a civilian and you would
have turned
i've only known two real dudes who are
real gangsters you know
and i remember one time my friend was
getting threats death threats from this
dude
and he's getting death threats and he
calls my buddy and he goes
hey um i'm really nervous i don't know
what to do and i never forgot
my buddy goes he's calling you and
telling you he's gonna [ __ ] you up that
means and he goes yeah he goes send him
your address and tell him when you're
going to be home
he's a pho he's he's a fan he goes no
he's
he goes hey do you think i would ever do
that
and it's true i never just show you i
never forgot what else is interesting
with that whack 100
you know he's breaking down takashi's
whole team he's like that guy take a
bullet for you that guy won't and
takashi was like no that's my business
guy he's like i can see in his eyes the
guns start flying he's [ __ ] running
and then tosh goes how do you know he
goes bro i made i grew up on the streets
man
my business is is knowing the end from
the first time i meet them
knowing what they're about of course
yeah he's life and death yeah he's like
instincts chunking information that's
what he's saying that's a smart dude
that guys
so so he tells so at the end of the the
podcast
he there they go so with takashi i
think's happening is i can see in his
eyes he's always he's not scared to die
he's already come to
reality like someone's eventually going
to get to him he's he's he wants to die
of martyr like he's
he's comfortable with it he's like
that's his problem he's ain't seeing his
eyes and josh goes 100
i made peace with diane a long time ago
when i met when i you know when i
snitched i made peace
so [ __ ] like [ __ ] dude he's so yeah
24. he's one tragic man 24. it's a
stressful way to live your life
and then when god was talking [ __ ] about
these certain gangs that oh geez like
bro
the hoover crit or the hoovers and the
whatever rolling 60s he's like
you go deeper they're like he's like
they've been at war for 60
years dude he's like this just comes way
before you you ain't
[ __ ] man he's like these street the way
they move this is going on way before
you i gotta listen to this [ __ ] what
is this a podcast mm-hmm
it's fantastic it's two and a half hours
long i can't get enough
what is it where what is
exclusively on spotify yeah send that to
me i gotta listen
to that [ __ ] again i'm so into because
it's so far out of the realm of anything
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and but when
you hear a real gangster break down
takashi 6'9
he's like you're not a gang you want to
act like a gangster and you're not so
he's trying to get him to admit that
he's not a gangster
and at the end dj academic shows i think
we've he goes we have more of these
conversations i think it's gonna help
and he goes so takashi do you still can
sell for gangster he goes [ __ ] yeah
knows
well we've learned nothing that's so
funny man i mean he's i mean what is
this he's got a double down on it i
guess
well i don't know but it is but it is i
mean that's
you know the kid like that has nothing
to lose yeah he's a little bit
out of it his face is covered in tattoos
but that og too he has a family and
stuff like that and
he's like even with me like my girl is
going to roll the rolling loud whatever
concert
she's with security yeah everybody knows
who i am i have enemies out there
she's with security it's like you should
be with security all the time
i wonder if you know this a quick
question for you brian cause you
talked about that talked about that
world before it's not like the way he
got in with those bloods or whatever you
can't do that with like mafia like my
mom
it's not you can't just like get in well
you're you're right your father has
a 100 percent sicilian i don't know it
all depends
i'm a little balls deep in that too okay
okay so so
you're is your mom's sister and your
dad's not my mom's sicilian 100
yes but your dad's not no so then you
could he he could he couldn't
you could be in this but you can't be a
man yeah so to be a
man that might have changed because i
know johnny a light wasn't 100 italian
he was like
you know he was a main trigger man so it
all depends
trigger's different jimmy burke jimmy
the gent burke uh from goodfellas he was
half hours half italian and that was
that's why he couldn't be made he can't
be made yeah
i i don't know that's what i was gonna
say like the mafia doesn't seem like
it's
the mafias had to change the old school
mafia
you know one of the things about cameras
everywhere on dashboards
on ring everywhere on the streets yeah
is that you can't get away with killing
people anymore they can all race
back you want some more sucker yeah this
counts been stretching dog
you got lucky hey i'm a lover not a
fighter you don't have to you don't have
to worry about me dog
but yeah i was curious because because
when i think about that stuff and the
way
he got him with the bloods or whatever
i'm like
i was like i don't i don't know like it
doesn't seem like it happens that easy
but no but that but talks about it he
goes
but even whack goes you shouldn't have
even been in that position he was
because you can get initiated like you
should in the gang
you're not from that hood like none of
it makes any sense that's that that's a
young man's name
but they saw you know that they could
benefit and make bags off you
and you need the security and the street
cred from them so it was a perfect storm
unfortunately
because but you should never been in the
gate like you should never been involved
that involved
i think it comes down to young men have
this need to be heroic
tough brave and if it's not if that
energy
that need and that is primal for a lot
of young men if that need isn't
channeled in the right direction in
sports in a ring
on a mat whatever you're gonna do and
you don't have parents
you're gonna do some dumb [ __ ] and
you're gonna end up getting shot or
killed because that real [ __ ] is how it
ends
jail or or and very few people like
whack 100 make it out yeah
but he you know you know what's
interesting 69 was trying to uh
reference other famous rappers who have
snitched returned
and he was like well like you ride with
um
uh rick ross he was like dude he was a
uh nick ross did a lot of time though
no no he was a regular officer but
what's interesting he goes he goes he
was in a gangster correctional offer
and whack 100 spent like 15 years in
prison
goes see young man that's where you're
[ __ ] up he goes you know who are the
most
gangster dudes in prison correctional
officers he goes how do you think we get
all the drugs
and the money and the [ __ ] shanks in
the prison here's those guys
those guys dictate what we can and can't
do he goes most of them are the most
gangster [ __ ] guys in that prison
because that's where you're [ __ ] up
so you're telling me that rick ross is a
gangster and he goes i don't know the
man like that
he goes but he can't say he was he goes
but i can't say he wasn't because we
don't have any proof
you're saying he wasn't and he's just
like a grown man
speaking to a young man but this guy has
his
[ __ ] black belt in the streets and
this kid's a blue belt
what is what is takashi 6'9 doing now is
he making music is he i think he's yeah
he still makes music he's really popular
still
he's really popular yeah really really
but that's what dj academic who's like
basically the voice of hip-hop besides
charlemagne dj is right there
okay so he's dj academic charlotte
maynard like the voice of the culture
but then also
that whack 100 goes i said this he goes
when he goes to prison he comes out he's
going to be bigger
he's in the culture we're in he's going
to be bigger oh what else is interesting
is he goes
well this guy said this and this guy
said this he's talking about like
snooping stuff like this
and whack goes who told you that because
the he rolls with the guy who's these
bloods you stomach
who told you that and the 69 was like
well i saw it on twitter and picks up
the
phone
you see that's your problem you listen
to the [ __ ] social media yeah because
gangsters aren't on social media
we're not going to get on there and tell
you our moves man because that's your
problem this ain't real
and you're all god dawg cause you're a
man i want
a friend man and then when when his when
he
switches on [ __ ] 21 savage like oh my
god yeah don't get it savage goes oh say
last night
yeah that's like that's like boxers like
real pro boxes like wayne mcculloch when
i would actually hit him
we'd be moving around and i would hit
him he would just turn it up without
even you
you're all of a sudden you're getting
[ __ ] punched in the face you know
it's like don't
don't get it twisted fighters are
fighters gangsters it's crazy
69 even after all this still isn't that
humble no it's it's
i wonder if it it's just something he
probably has that's what
because you're not from the streets and
i get you don't realize how lucky you
like you have no idea how to touch it
yeah
yeah i don't know i just think going
back to what you said with like the
young man stuff like it like that primal
like to be the
and what we were talking about a little
bit earlier like
with mark you like you know like just
the importance of like
doing a sport and being coached and like
having your ego
you know just like shattered sometimes
by a coach like telling you
you're not [ __ ] or something like that
just to you know and then all of a
sudden you take that
and grow with that and understand like
oh what what uh
the world of being humble is you know
what i mean like
in sports you have to learn to work with
all these different personalities oh
it's like different personalities
me and chrissy just definitely putting
together a tour called the thick chaos
tour
and i i've i've harped on and you know
this for so long
how we need to do the the blue comedy
tour again and like everybody gets
together you do these huge theaters
well chrissy the reason me and chrissy d
get along so well is
chris like chrissy d's not crazy
chrissy d grew up he's relaxing team
sports he's stable
and you know he he played college
basketball so he's used to a team so
when i say this he there we reciprocate
each other yeah it's awesome and
and then chrissy dude goes i think you
and i vibe he goes because we come from
team sports
like we we get give and take he's like
we're not bigger than that i don't come
from team sports but i've always been
that guy yeah
i've always been yeah i i never
understood how most comments
and i won't mention names most comics
are not
all of them dude when i tried to steve
harvey the the the [ __ ]
rat pack comedy tour yeah after a week i
was like i'm out
i'm out [ __ ] off because this guy i
want this guy need to be on the cover
oh my picture needs to be bigger and i
need this much more money i'm like bro
it's pretty i've never it's like the ufc
it's like it's pretty black and white
like you sell this one i have
never understood i have never understood
how they don't understand that strength
exists in numbers and i mean
we can make we can have great memories
still make decent money and have great
memories we can actually
no we can actually make all the money on
the road because what happens is if you
look at blue collar comedy tour
if you have a great tour and people are
really funny that's how [ __ ] blows up
and then you do a special of 20 minutes
each
whatever it might be well when you think
about both of those both of those
specials like the blue collar comedy
tour and the kings
those still like hold its weight today
in 2021 but they are changing the
launching pad for all
and who was giving them problems and
they kicked them off the tour remember i
can't remember who it was so steve
harvey
he's the mastermind behind all these
dudes he's amazing so there was a guy on
there who was like man i should be
closing the show out blah blah blah and
then he was complaining that a car
didn't pick him up
oh steve harvey went oh we're good yeah
why he goes no we'll find somebody
yeah i think that's what the brother
said no they brought d.l that's right
yeah
and bernie mac most people don't realize
bernie sanders
like he was he was still like you know
he was still burnt bernie mac but he
wasn't like he's
bernie mac yeah and based off of that
tour
he that's how we got the bernie mac tv
show but how great
to talk about teamwork so bernie mac was
you know he wasn't as famous as any of
those guys he was the least famous guy
but he was the best comic so first first
first night on the tour
they all go on but bernie goes first
shuts the [ __ ] place down where
cedric and all the boys are looking each
other like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] damn you gotta follow that yeah but
they're monsters they do this
second second on tour in another city
same thing hey bernie you close
the thing down bernie even asked for it
cedric came out i was like hey i think
you should go live you got to close bro
yeah okay but that's but it wasn't like
it wasn't like bernie was like hey i
should you i know
that's digging a hole and bernie mac is
a good comic star
we're not there's not a sport we're all
here here we are we're having fun
and and you know the i remember if if
you ever see rogan and i did uh meat
eater the first episode we ever did
and rogan we're about to hunt we're in
the missouri breaks
and rogan goes we're representing we're
representing comics man got to do a good
job and i look at rogue and i go yeah
that unified bunch he starts laughing so
hard but it was so true it's like
stop acting like anybody here gives a
[ __ ] i you know no
none of them none of that if he doesn't
do it well it wouldn't be like how dare
you like down the comedy
yeah but all those dudes all those dudes
like from the blue collar and kings of
comedy
are selling out shows today and what
those specials were like
almost 20 years ago they're selling out
arenas that's what i'm saying
so it's like you know sometimes
you gotta i don't know it's hard to get
you guys to see the big picture
yeah yeah it's definitely impossible
there's a there's a long one especially
now there's a long play to it especially
now where
all those dudes are still relevant
it's tough to convince him like hey you
know don't do this city because we do
this with the
with you know whatever the thick cast
tour and you know yeah like do i have
that city in eight months i'm like
i know dude you're only burning 20
minutes 20 minutes
and then if you're gonna get new fans
then you can go back there in six months
and you sell even more tickets is that
what they did on blue collars dude they
only do like 20 minutes
i don't i don't know what they did i
think it was
yeah that's how i found out about ron
white well ron white got his
that's what blew him up oh it was a dude
he's also awesome but yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gotta have that you gotta have
the talent and then they came up there
together and kind of like did their
little riffing thing
man there's a group at yeah
to watch how podcasting has changed
comedy is amazing too
not for the worst either for in a lot of
ways for the better but oh for sure i
mean
yeah but you were able to make money
way faster as a comic you know comics
didn't make money yeah none of us made
money back
even the good old show that's all you
want to do you want to get a tv show and
get off the road yeah
brian was such a [ __ ] yeah and
and now all of a sudden people
there's still a few guys like that yeah
like that are
like they're just doing it to jump to
something else jump to something else
get off but they've also been doing it
forever and
i understand like that road life yeah
yeah after after a certain point yeah
we're gonna find a [ __ ]
you know buffalo and then the next week
you're in miami it's like and then
you're flying back to l.a like it's a
beast yeah
i mean honestly the greatest job in the
world but you know it's a beast yeah
honestly if eddie murphy
yeah like when i think about eddie
murphy it's like i mean
he probably you know has the itch for
comedy and that's probably why he wants
to get back into it
but i mean honestly if i i mean if it
were me and i had his career i'd
probably be like
yeah yeah yeah i got my family
a couple of intimate sets of the story
everything yeah
but like he still does movies money
money money does dull your instrument
most of the time most
unless you're most happy with that
unless you're in [ __ ] heart
what are you saying well money money
will a lot of times dull your instrument
it'll it'll
um you're not relatable right yeah or it
just makes you not
quite entirely desperate you heard
something a little bit well you'd think
like
the thing about kevin hart's material is
now all about family yeah he's not gonna
tell you how much money he has i feel
like majority
majority of it's all about his family
which everybody can relate to it's not a
i think kevin's work ethic is on point
i just think he does he stretches
himself out a little too much like
it's like he does everything and i don't
think you can be great at doing it when
you do
10 projects at once and you got to be a
little careful with it yeah
and it's really hard because kevin
though he i mean name one thing he does
that's been bad lately
yeah he's all the [ __ ] over dude his
show on top gear
whatever it is him and his boys they
have the car show you know
he hosted the olympics oh yeah the
special
he's just awesome he's also so good yeah
and
so funny and nobody likes being silly
more
nobody likes laughing oh yeah he's a
silly goose
and generous as [ __ ] as a human being
just in spirit
he's a very good he takes care of all
his bullets his boys
are great too all the guys around him
are great yeah they're all great those
guys
what are they calling the paper club
boys yeah they're playing boys every one
of those [ __ ]
uh they're all great guys uh uh
special specials yeah they good you know
because they're all good or hours
uh i don't know i don't think it's our i
don't
know
i think all i like every one of those
guys i mean yeah like i mean certain
guys i mean
i mean you're adam sandler he takes care
of his dudes yeah i mean they all
i always respect that i always
appreciate that he always puts
but like you know doesn't seem like out
of touch
and seems like he's able to still like
relate like they do to go out
just on the street and play basketball
pick up basketball game with random
people
that's what you want that's the way you
want to be you know and then meanwhile
this guy's got
massive amount of money but like it's
like it's it's all
i think it is always interesting when
you see people with
especially when it comes to the comedy
world where they do have so much money
but there's but they're they still have
that skill to be able to relate
to people the goal is to be able to
simplify everything right
yeah so the money money for your bills
man and you don't have enough money for
your children for sure
yeah and that last special that special
that adam sandler did
[ __ ] amazing unique for sure yeah and
he did that song about chris farley was
[ __ ] yeah makes everybody teary-eyed
i know you know
so sad [ __ ] that's a crazy story we got
chin
looking it up right now um how's that
new keyboard
is that what we call it keyboard
switchboard it's a video mixer video
switcher
producer slash fighter
i mean i saw what you did yesterday you
tried
uh this is pretty cool brandon don't
kyle and christian want to fight you
to get like oh yeah so since we were
trying to get you out the door me and
brian well actually it's just me
to be honest right brian yeah brian so
we're gonna probably have uh
christian and kyle try to get me out the
door that makes sense yeah
because it seems like the same you know
you don't want these problems that's
gonna be hard i'm
has hot energy he's got hot energy but
he's small
he's skinny chin he's i mean not that
skinny
pretty skinny yeah christian's scrappy
man i'm skinny fat which is
a bummer but we'll change that soon
right bro
i heard that brennan's shop school for
jiu-jitsu was going to take me and kyle
under his wing
i mean that's just what i was told
brennan's got those nasty i like how it
has to take two people for chen
this thing i mean i guess they're tiny
yeah they're smaller
hey but i don't mean nothing i wouldn't
fight henry
yeah that'd be a bad idea exactly have
you ever seen bugs life the two little
uh guys that jump on each other i
remember bugs life but i don't bring a
bug's life it's the two i think
they might be rolly police i don't but
they're that's too short
they're two short bugs and when they
fight they jump on one gets on your
shoulders hey he's a trench coat too
yeah henry's bigger than uh
i he was saying height little taller
what are you again five forward right
there really yeah they're there
yep you're five that's christian and
kyle you stay here
uh should be maybe five three yeah he's
so tiny that's hilarious but he's gotta
walk around at 160. right now no
god no no damn i'm uh you kill these
references
tiny tiny guy that's you guys there you
go
there you go christian and kyle fighting
chin
chin's the big beetle yeah does does
dana what
wants to fight again but he's not being
allowed to that's what i heard the fight
i'm gonna fight i'll call you one few
months
after i heard him he has to wait because
he wants to fight peter young but peters
by al jermain
oh okay and then if he wants to fight
brandon he'd fight bran more you know if
he wants to come out
it'll be a fun fight so he does want to
fight though oh yeah henry wants to
fight
good [ __ ] moreno well i don't bet
against henry cejudo in any
nor should you i'd like to see peter yan
and him go but
say who doesn't nightmare but think
about it like it's a little complicated
because
peter john has to fight al jermain he
beats him he's tj's guaranteed next time
shot
so you have to get through tj and then
so henry your henry's out
you know late until next year the only
thing about peter young is he got great
hips he can sprawl he's got good
takedown defensively
and great boxing but to be great boxing
means i gotta get in your grill
and you're very open for a double or
single leg so cejudo's going to take him
down that's
that's i don't know so who's not a big
double guy but i feel you
he's not bad yeah
but yeah i mean i mean it's [ __ ]
happening you're going to get that close
to a wrestler
so good yeah
alrighty so we haven't heard from
brendan frazier in quite some time right
i know that i always pride myself on
being the most famous brand one of the
nicer people on the planet
for sure apparently has a piece on him
that would have trouble getting into
this room no no no
no to be he's aging like a raisin
he is aging strongly there he is
but he's returning with like two really
big movies still better here than brian
uh what'd you say chin so this is a
martin's i think he probably
has a knife for that that looks like uh
those look like plugs that's 100 percent
looks like
well he's a human hedgehog so that's
no he had to get big for a roll right he
puts weight on video
one of the best looking guys at that
time but he and father time said hey
come here real quick
well start losing weight i started
losing his hair and started eating a
little too much that's that's a lot of
fun maybe just got paid and was like
what was that movie he did but a good
man something mummy
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah let me see
him let me see him when he was young and
awesome
but real quick this is a cast for this
uh this martin gross case that's that's
that's my score
movie dicaprio he's coming out big
wow um all right so you wanna see him
younger
is it a movie about gangsters clearly oh
yeah
i don't see anything besides gangster
wait is it a true story hold on
never mind flower moon killers of the
flower moon
it was the fire i wanna why don't you
use that photo for him i think jesse
he looks like that now members of a saga
tribe in the united states are murdered
under mysterious circumstances
in the 1920s okay i've been oh okay i'm
in for that
okay a major fbi investigating involving
j edgar hoover
uh who's a gay man so that's cool that's
my favorite movie raising ball right
there
what facts oh yeah what's that uber was
gaming yes he was dressed up in women's
clothing yeah what
there's in the mummy right there no he's
got a well there's a dog
there he is there he is with his long
hair look at his body there
that's george of the jungle yeah big big
kid all every bit of six
three um the handsome machine one of the
best looking involved
no he's he is still your girl
but you know he doesn't care anymore i
forgot he doesn't i saw him in an
interview he doesn't care at all
hair heads yeah yeah he'll steal your
mother he's such a nice guy though man
he's such a good guy
there's this isn't he no that's not a
sino man that's in our heads
oh our heads okay oh yeah it's great
adam sandler
yeah and uh steve uh
who wouldn't such a liberal god
oh yeah that's encino man yeah yeah
paulie shore polish yep dude brendan
frazier and polly short should do a
podcast together
uh son-in-law that's a good movie i love
that movie yeah paulie
i like paul [ __ ] oh yeah i love paul
that's my buddy yeah i love paulie
i've seen him in a long time he's good
people
well okay connor
this i just thought was interesting
because i'll show you in a second
you see some random girl so he's just in
l.a getting getting some like dinner and
then he's walking to his car
with his crutches and there's some girl
right next to him behind him
what's up
oh
so she made it past those guys right
there yeah but there's obviously he's
also with a bunch of uh huh
yeah you're looking great but if you
keep one so if connor has a side piece
trust me no it's not yeah
that's his job do you guys think like
some of them genuinely show up and like
just know that the person is there
like we were talking about last time how
like some people some celebs are like
hey i'll be here i don't think connor's
yeah yeah from the right because gives
the restaurant publicity
so the girl working the front desk is
gonna call tmz hey connor's here
if you see that black uh woman who got
up and just started doing sign language
at the press conference i saw sam trippy
turns out she does noise
[Music]
she's faking it just to get it
somebody's outrageous
she's doing jingle bells right now she's
not singing
watch this [ __ ] it's just so [ __ ]
funny right there right there right
there watch this
y'all remember her
she waved her arms around like she was
singing jingle bells
says one outraged sign language expert
the woman
identified as oh god
i [ __ ] old shots i love her lord
the woman simply showed up that is
hilarious is this in l.a she's all
ah she's great come on man you gotta
love her
that we have one here she's a fraud but
she's doing a great job look at her man
i love her she waved her arms around
come on that [ __ ] is funny that is funny
it's a little crazy but yeah
ah but it's just such a goof also such a
random thing to just be a friend oh yeah
why do you want to be in there yeah what
yeah it's so boring
yeah but she's that's what she does
she's a fraudster
that is an ak-47 oh that is yeah 47.
that's an affair
oh it is yeah oh okay well yeah that was
just someone
sent this to me too like in san
francisco i guess drive-by shootings are
growing up
and this one was uh some random girl
sticking out outside of a window
and she fired it that's nice and then
the ak-47 is the right that's the
[ __ ]
shot one yes jesus christ it's a kick i
can't imagine oh my god
yeah yeah it's not like shooting an
ar-15 no big
not russians was it a five five three or
something seven six two
seven six two or something alright take
it easy yeah yeah
seven six two one store that's true yeah
you didn't told us that a hundred times
i talked about
i never talked to christian he was
working at a gun store i talked to these
uh
the soldiers who said when in
afghanistan when they would shoot and
they have it on auto
they never really never have to worry
about it because they would shoot and
the gun would just kick up automatically
so the bullets go over your head
and then they go on jesus
when is your gun on auto like when he
goes never i'm never on auto yes
i go no but i mean when are you laying
cover because i'm never on auto okay
don't say lane cover he goes
auto yeah he goes auto is for actors and
[ __ ] okay so don't
actors and [ __ ] yeah then i then my
somebody guys like i wear
he wears a scarf because you know when
you're in a fire fight the guy's hot
bullets
fall into your neck and andy calls me
and goes anybody standing that close to
you in a fire fight
is a tactical [ __ ] [ __ ] love andy
okay some of cats current events here
so this mother is actually filipina
and her husband's nigerian and i guess a
lot of people are asking like
is that your baby or whatever so this is
like a clap back to them weird
yeah and her sister [ __ ] baby is that
your kid or you borrow the neighbor
on tick tock hold on she's pretty
question um when the pandemic first
started my neighbor started this
business called borrow my black baby and
i thought
perfect it was
time to start my career on tick tock um
as a tick tock mom but i didn't have a
black baby
so um i asked my husband will you make
a black baby with me and he said you
know i don't see the value in that i
said it's good for views he said i don't
care
and so you know until i can convince him
that baby's so [ __ ] cute
to our future um yes she's so funny
continuing to borrow my neighbor's black
baby
she's great she's [ __ ] great
i love
that baby is so cute she looks like me
she is easy on the eyes
she's easy on the eyes intelligent and
funny i'm a little bit
that baby's so cute have a picture with
your birthday cake growing up
was that chappelle's dad
he's got a gift is that chappelle
in five years i mean
is that chappelle with a graybeard
chapel holy [ __ ]
dude you think i'll have gray hair in
five years uh
maybe ten i have like little i don't
know something
what two years three years i mean ten
but yeah
no i mean but i was like how old were
you in seventh grade
i don't know you tell me i don't know
i'm great you didn't have great warriors
three years ago a little bit it happened
like i got greg right well we first met
he had like
[ __ ] flesh here yeah no
god's his barber still still good
looking tough here what else you got jim
wait spell are you into asian girls at
all or no [ __ ] yeah yeah wait
what's your like dream like dream girl
like what type
girlfriend right now i know yes dude
why i don't see color but i would
imagine
you don't talk about it no yeah i don't
talk about it what what
what why it's not that interesting of a
topic
what she's great what what do you want
to say struck a chord
i know certain coordination is like what
about it christian
she's not that exciting she's on my page
i posted a picture
you actually post pictures yeah you said
one of my pages uh no no okay
i mean a hot second ago but like also
but if you had like a hundred guesses
christian you guess white
yeah and i'll show you if i had one
guess if i gave you one thousand guesses
all thousands be white oh no
um quite some time ago okay two years
ago
no it's not that's cool it's not [ __ ]
not that far down
y'all talking [ __ ] holy crap
it's coming up oh [ __ ] yeah she's super
pretty we went to
uh dinner with she's gorgeous yeah super
yeah
congratulations you're crazy if you
don't look like that guy congratulations
dude
yeah i'm crazy if i don't look like that
guy pull that guy
hey your quote said love is tight and
the other guy put and blind apparently
and blind wow oh really
that's a great that's great though
that's funny i'll kick his ass
and i'm just kidding i don't know the
guy elon musk oh nice guy lames
accidental tap for following twitter
user
some girl got really excited because she
got followed by elon musk
and then he says sorry accidental tap
and unfolder yeah
gangster because he don't follow anybody
right then look what this girl says
you want can you accidentally tap this
yeah yeah she's bad too
yeah he's a billionaire ever wants his
dick you know yeah yeah
we and then they're saying he's talking
about they've said that we've all done
that i've actually done that yeah
when you're going through you actually
hit royal what's up man appreciate that
i feel terrible
and you looked at my twitter and i was
following all these porn
things but i had i didn't even know how
to follow anybody i didn't have a photo
and i call and go
i don't know how i did that ryan that's
crazy yeah
uh yeah there was a bunch of porn on
twitter i didn't know how to i didn't
know how to deal with this
i didn't even know how to unfollow him
show porn on twitter
trisha paytas she's insane she literally
has her open [ __ ] on her twitter i'm
not even kidding what does it look like
i wouldn't wish out a pile i don't know
bring it up jen what is it what's her
name
what's her name yeah what's your name
trisha paytas and how do you know her
yeah she was like around david dobrik
and like she's updated one of his
friends and they
[ __ ] on her all the time there she was
clinically insane yeah
she's your predator is this oh the fat
one
oh okay well we know all right yeah she
i just i
just don't like yeah she she she used to
have a show with homeboy from uh what's
your college
she used to do a podcast yeah she's a
she's a porn star
no not an actress i wouldn't call her a
star if anything
but but why is why is her booty hole i
don't see anybody oh i know
she did she said a nice thing about me
actually
go to the media i think a long time ago
and then your booty hall laying on there
see if i click on it keep scrolling down
and you'll see it trust me
i didn't know she post stuff like i
think she's the one i i kind of like
stuck up for on this talk show i did and
i think she'd posted
i just don't know i don't know who would
pay for her only facts remember
she went harder what do you mean pay for
her only fans
she looks like it's thanksgiving i think
i'm wrong bruh
she's not terrible you're wild bro it's
cause you little she's kind of sexy
there right
right there yeah keep going i can't
decide can't decide
can't decide that's not far down bro she
doesn't have anything you've gone on in
a while
booty hole picks on here she did for the
longest i think she's cute personally
yeah she's yes thank you yeah there's
something sexy about her she's sexy
are you guys a hater
yeah christian yeah she she's got a lot
of hatefulness no
[ __ ] pictures christian by the way
i'll tell you this there are a lot of
men that love her i'll tell you yeah
yeah
of course starting with you like you're
not afraid of that
and i'm not no no one has a favorite
point of view
she's she's christian's afraid of you
two yeah no no no no
no like thick girls it's just her as a
person too i just don't like her and i
don't think
all the [ __ ] she said and all the stuff
i've seen yeah i don't like her she
seems like a piece of [ __ ] was she a
reality girl
you don't know the lady no she got
famous opportunity
this way i could see that how she's a
kind of a scumbag when
she would go around is this in fact
yeah yeah oh what is this she would when
she was dating jason nash
sheesh what oh no that's keep going she
would go uh she would
get mad if he talked to anyone like like
he talked to a girl before they were
even dating and she freaked out on him
yet she would do all scummy [ __ ] like
show him pictures with her
with some other dudes dick in his mouth
you don't know their relationship like
that
dog this is online world like yeah this
is exactly what we're going to talk
about
and we're whack one hug how's jason nash
doing yeah
what is that your boy who's johnny oh
he's not my boy buddy but yes
i've known him for 23 years oh yeah
since new york
yeah i've known jason i think he's
thought you talking about different
jason jason nash blonde hair stand up
comedian
10 guy is he older yeah there he is oh
you dated her i've known jason for 26
years
i love him 23 years yeah he's is he
uh he was married i guess not anymore
yeah he got married he when he got
divorced that's when him and trisha pay
to start
dating oh he's like a skateboarder yeah
he um
he was a comic and i don't know what
he's doing a vlogger now yeah
okay david dober can't he was doing
standup david dover came into his show
and gave everyone their money back
well in the middle of his set which i
thought was [ __ ] hysterical
yeah he was uh well you know what he was
in the online world a lot yes i got into
it
i have a youtube world i got into it
during the pandemic before that not
really
that's a lot that's dude that's too much
i don't know anything too much
yeah but are you just out here hating on
this you don't know their relationship
you don't know what it was
everything i've heard i've never i
haven't heard one until
do you guys know who princess eugenie is
i don't know but she shouldn't apologize
do i
like to see her well this is not her but
this is a model i guess princess
eugenie's husband
was found on a yacht with three
different women and then this girl had
her bikini top off and she said the
reason it was office because it got wet
so she had to take it off
the guy's married to princess eugenie
wait hold up
who's the teen wolf on the right and
then who's the non-keto guy in the
middle
which one's the prince
post teen wolf on the teen wolf is the
prince
yeah holy [ __ ] that's funny so this guy
yeah he's got he's got to do some best
should hang on to whatever he got
and that's a lot he is a prince but
that's his wife the one with the
rottweiler had
well that is princess eugenie and her
husband why did you who's teen wolf on
the right who's that
wow no we can't go over that no we have
to
did you hear what he just said about
this woman's [ __ ]
the rottweiler that isn't that a little
bit are you doing rather said
they're threatened oh wow well you know
yeah
that's one of the monsters
i know it's uncomfortable i mean it's
uncomfortable it's all hard
when you look that good isn't there
something about just being free and
dude if you ever see your girl on the
yacht and nobody else in the picture
shocking there's only one way to pay for
that yacht you don't think that she's
there for her personality
probably she should probably good good
she don't know how to steer the ship
she's there for one reason why i don't
know i'm so confused right now i would
imagine she's let's be honest though
she's all right friendships you're
skinny well a little too skinny don't
too skinny
spells rock hard right now but yeah no i
can't not she why now
now she might she might surprise you
with with her naughtiness sometimes
sometimes you get somebody's bone thin
and a deep pervert and that's a whole
different situation yeah
i mean i mean i'm just saying so it all
depends all hands on
dick let's do it all hands on dick
yeah she's living her best life man hey
she plays tennis brian a little skinny
for me
wait you light in the ass for me yeah i
feel like your brain did she's got it
she's like a reindeer see that see that
see that private jet
yeah you don't think she's flying it's
not pilot you don't think she's paying
attention she's
hey she's not serving drinks kids so she
didn't
oh she didn't oh when we get in there
when we get in the air you're getting
nuts i like this guy hey we get in the
air hold on my seatbelt's coming off and
guess what
what you getting i'm so confused dude
they're not honey roasted daddy but i
don't understand it i feel like she's
yeah she's there because she's bringing
her personality to the table what's
oh go ahead what are you saying you're
nuts
well that's a private beach somewhere
and she paid to get there
oh no i bet she has a ton of money she's
working real hard but she has another
private jet
although she is skiing in the alps oh
are we getting those slopes
ah you think you're getting hot
chocolate after this
hey i don't you think we're gonna chill
and you're drinking hot cocoa i have a
great personality i'm independent i'm
intelligent yeah yeah and i'm funny my
friends say i'm funny sure
my friends say i'm funny sure put the
coco down because it's time to go to
work for them riding a horse there
mm-hmm and i watched it good horseback
riding yeah that's it that's a photo
shoot
mm-hmm this one there she was nice a
ferrari yeah that one
yeah that's a 10-foot hoop and that's a
basketball
that's uh there's there's not a lot of
she's she's gorgeous yeah you playing
doubles she's a model with my
nuts you feel me dude i don't know what
you're talking about bro i'm gonna ask
you to please
keep your i mean she oh this she's
another private jet she might want to do
that she might be an entrepreneur she
maybe she's
going to be an entrepreneur she looks
like she works for the money and that's
all i'm trying to do
i will give her this looks like she has
a fantastic life i'll give her that does
have a fantastic life
and the music will stop eventually magic
knives musical stuff make sure you marry
either keto guy
non-keto guy or or no deal with the
hairy boy teen wolfer you gotta
get with hairy boy oh she's got a gap is
that a gap a little bit
much she also it's like two big front
teeth like
why i think there's like big chicklets
very cute big chicklets
very cute but um yeah not our not our
spirit
board she's not getting on my private
jet if i had one
if you haven't she getting on your
private jet uh yeah
yeah why not yeah christian's in for it
i i think dan bilzerian had the best
looking women
ever yeah the the bilzerian girls are
the girls
i think is he back on social media yet
he was offered
he's in vegas though my boy just hung
out with where'd he go why do you get
off social media just to hate
uh i don't think that laid low you know
well come see me with that princess
chester though what
see me in houston uh august 19 2021
and then i'll be at uh in god i'll be in
buffalo
helium it's a great club floor plane
trip dude
search sucking dick flight private i
might denver colorado comedy works
if you're just an old twink you just fly
private i would like to be worried
if i didn't only fans how much money do
you think i would seven dollars
that's it yeah what would i do on online
show your [ __ ]
i subscribe what i have to do you have
jack off there's probably some younger
gay dudes out there that like a
little older man no no no what we need
to do is get you a young like rich twink
but daddy to fly private to buffalo
it's a lot of money huh his friends are
gonna have to join why
oh i don't think anybody i don't know if
your heart can handle it i'm not making
it
you might be right it's something to
consider man
you know it's not a bad idea though dude
you just get like some young twink who's
rich as [ __ ] yeah now you're taking
pictures on yachts wait
do i have to but i got to do something
with the twink do you know
i'm sorry do you know how to do you know
how to stare a [ __ ] cruise ship
no well i can learn
sure oh so do i have to be i got to be
i got to pay i'll put this one i'm the
old guy who hasn't you'll be ready to go
at
all times but that means i have to have
sex with him though and he's a bro
so oh so he's banging daddy's working
wait hold on i gotta know
though the thing is i don't think he's
going to have sex with me he wants me to
have sex with him
no no no no no no no you don't use that
honey hole's getting yeah
my old my old honey hole's taking a
beating i know it's a nightmare i don't
understand
how this came private to buffalo so i
get a private jet
yeah but you give me pretty well you get
to do stand up you get to do your shows
would you could you even consider that
dead honest like if if some young twink
heard this like i have a private jet i
like brian
i was like dude i'll fly up for the rest
of this tour for the rest of year
all he has to do is [ __ ] me everybody
every now and then no i'm dead serious
hold on like
let me ask you this see how you got yeah
would you consider it hit me up
at brian what about this let's say you
were single right yeah and it was an
old lady like dude like 75
non-kilo sure looks like my grandma but
she has a [ __ ]
private jet a big yacht yeah she'll fly
all over the country yeah
once a month yeah you're gonna have to
do some work no problem
you would be up for it right the problem
is how do i get it up i got to do a lot
of uh seattle
you don't think you could get it from
you daddy uh i don't know
what if you watch like porno and then
you're like come in now you got to do
your best yeah
you'd have to what do i get for it come
here margaret you get any
anywhere you want to go private jet so
for your entire tour yeah then when
you're off you get a standard house
rent-free you get food and i have a taco
all the clothes you can handle and i
have to talk to my girl and i go
once a month though you just once a
month you're staying with her all night
if you don't do that you're a [ __ ]
suck it up right now now she smells like
oatmeal cookies
i like oatmeal cookies even better even
better
i like oatmeal cookies i bet there's
some guys who do that they're going to
do it you guys should do that
no i get kids no no no if you're single
had no kids
hey i have kids too you [ __ ] yeah you
did yeah you gave him this situation you
guys are older now though
yeah but it's just once a month bubba
and you went in and they never find out
yeah i i physically can't
what i couldn't yeah it would last one
month
and she's like dude you're the worst
it's hard to do hard to get
you don't think you can get it up i just
feel like a dirt bag
getting it up is very difficult like for
that situation for that type of
situation think about because yeah all
right
last one then let's end this yeah
handsome young man
and all you have to do is jack them off
but you stare them in the eye
once a month drag them off just a hard
jacket one video
okay not like this like all right oh yes
look
oh yeah do me a favor where do i sign to
do it where do i
sign yeah i'd probably be more open to
that than well of course you would oh my
gosh
now here's the problem but all my
friends i'd be down for margaret dawg
let me ask you you go morgan
you got to put your mouth on it now hold
on no no he's not good-looking
and he's got a big heavy piece hold on
he's very shredded clean he's clean
and he's got he's got a potty lips peace
on it he's a very good looking man
you got to kiss him no don't hold on
dude i'm not done you have to
i'm already out though before yourself
you gave him all these situations let
him yeah mine's just jacking him off
dude he's talking about
bringing up elizabeth hurley's son yeah
he is oh that guy broke me and
now he's bringing up the other night in
bed he's a beauty and i said how old are
you
i said he's a beautiful human being my
girl goes he's all right when you're out
of your mind
now hold on and she goes are you gay i
go i might be no
no i went to bed look at this giant he's
gorgeous
now dude he's a gorgeous human be honest
be honest
now i want you to wait that's a that's
some yes
that's it's his mom but he's a dude so
all you got to do bubba look
that's a dude dude go to his ig once a
month i'm gonna give you a hundred
million dollars yes
wait what i slowed down i didn't i
didn't even ask a question question
i thought i thought to hang out no no
that's
he's a beautiful he's definitely gay
right or something
yeah no he's probably just model no no
he
did come on i thought that was him
there's one girl right there
fellas straight guys don't eat like that
you don't take pictures
with nah he he his eyebrows are too
daunting a handsome kid
yeah he's a good looking human being
well he's very feminine you know he
knows what he's doing yeah
also his hair's better than nine nah he
about to kiss that girl right there bruh
nah yeah
well he's a gorgeous human being so
there are a lot of people that would
want to have sex with them including
brennan
i'm gonna need him to shave down though
chappelle yeah could you do it with him
hell no i could hey i'll
i think if you spend enough time with
him have you had like a really dope
personality
yeah you'd kiss him i would make out
with him oh the kissing's weird he's
beautiful
he's beautiful i take it easy and then i
i think i think
you said beautiful how many times you
would 100 let him do things to you
for money i don't think so dude you're
such a [ __ ]
baby you know that you're [ __ ]
disappointed good looking creature
you're such a [ __ ] you really are
you're telling me that that that
beautiful young lady or whatever
i mean she he is beautiful he's he's
just a mom he's not an actor or anything
is that his daughter too is that his
sister i mean where
that whole family is they're all about
him that's his girl his mom is such a
dime
oh his mom is one of the hottest of all
time of all time oh why because bill
clinton used to fly her for booty calls
the white house i have no
facts i believe that bags
the ultimate [ __ ] boy of all [ __ ] boys
bill clinton used to fly her into the
white house she is the hottest thing
ever
ever ever dude and she's still english
she's stupid and a great actress
she's great at everything look at her
she's so hot dude her accent
she's so hot her and um uh who was
married to
sean sean uh who's married to sean penn
uh robin wright
you always say that look at elizabeth
look at him look at her dude
look at her there wait clinton go go go
that one yeah
that one that one with the yeah that one
look at her imagine that's your mom
all right dude look at her no you
another proposition for you she has
money you can fly private
and you can [ __ ] her every every night
if you want she's open to it
we have to cut off your arm no i know
you need mom
i know you need your arm what about a
hand you mean like that i like my hand
you mean like king slayer
gold hand i would but i got to have it
well i can keep it all right how about
what about your ear cut off stupid i'll
give you in here
yeah i mean i get to be with her forever
and all right what about this
i cut off from the knee down left leg
but we'll give you a robotic
and you're faster look at her look at
her skin so nice
oh it's it's insane you got to
understand guys if you if you if i get
to meet her
when she's like 20 and then she looks
that way for the next 35 years
you are set oh no you're going to hell
for the rest of your life because you've
clearly made a deal with it
you've made a deal with the devil it's
so worth it she's it's so worth it dude
i would [ __ ]
shovel fire for satan for her she's
single she is
something else i look at her dude she's
my age bro
she's [ __ ] my age oh my god and i
have a friend who had sex with her no
i do do i know him uh-huh no uh-huh
no i heard she's uh she was with hugh
graham dude i heard she is a
tom hat in the center i got i got bill
clinton
the most powerful man in the world was
flyer for booty i got
i got some gossip for you in general by
the way i forgot to tell you oh can't
wait yeah i know
seems like she's single yeah well that's
an outrage
53 yeah she looks you don't look better
than that at 53.
no no i mean if you're brian callum but
oh my god
all nettie yeah it could be in the
morning all you gotta do is chop one of
your arms off i think she's
all natty and she's rich as [ __ ] and
intelligent yep
she lives in she lives in london hugh
grant was married to her
yeah i didn't realize i didn't know that
she's legend legend too he's great too
i don't wear that outfit ever again but
that's fine
she's something else man yeah
smoke show yeah well that's it i'm in
north carolina
august 19th to 21st north carolina
then la jolla economy store no more
sunday show cause i have a fight command
so thursday the 26th through the 28th
that's uh
thursday 7pm two shows friday two shows
saturday in la jolla california
comedy store baby san jose september 9th
through 11th
san antonio texas september 24th through
25th
and we will have a fight companion
tomorrow night saturday
starts at 6 45 p.m we got brian ortega
t.j dillashaw josh thompson mark the
body harley and myself
all for the ufc 265 fight companion
live on twitch and thick boy youtube
channel
see you there kids your dates already
burned up brian
uh yeah
uh there i am
august 26 bray improv one night only uh
tampa florida october 7th through the
9th at side splitters
october 28th through the 30th washington
dc the dc comedy loft
november 17 tacoma comedy club one night
november 18th
uh spokane comedy club one night
unless the collab with built shirts and
thick boy
but they won't drop till probably uh
september but they're coming this is the
prototype
that material is so nice yeah filthy all
right kids love you bye